مشهد غير مالوف رسمه موسم حرائق الغابات
الشائع في سماء كندا سحابه دخان برتقاليه
صدمت خبراء الارصاد الجويه وعلماء المناخ
السنه لها بنقضت على ثلاثه ملايين وثمائه
الف هكتار من مقاطعه الكنديه اي ما يقارب
15 ضعف المتوسط في عشر سنوات بحسب الخبراء
ولليوم الثاني على التوالي الحرائق لا
تزال مشتعله لتطال الشرق والغرب من كندا
في ان واحد لاول مره في بدايه لاسوا موسم
حرائق على الاطلاق في تاريخ البلاد
ضباب دخاني كثيف خلفته الحرائق اجتاح سماء
نيويورك وصولا الى واشنطن تاثر بانبعاثته
الدخانيه 61 مليونا وثمانمائه الف شخص في
مختلف الولايات الامريكيه اجبروا على
مغادره منازلهم ارقام وصفها الخبراء
بمستويات غير مسبوقه في تدهور خطير لجوده
الهواء على الساحل الشرقي للولايات
المتحده فقط الخمسين ميكرو جراما لكل متر
مكعب من الهواء
القراءات الامريكيه لجوده الهواء تشير
لكونها الاسوا لاي مدينه حول العالم
فالجسيمات الصغيره المنبعثه وهي اصغر من
عرض شعره الانسان تشكل خطرا على الصحه
كونها تخترق الرئتين ومجرى الدم بالتالي
تفقم حده الامراض الخطيره لا سيما الجهاز
التنفسي والقلب
ومع توقعات باستمرار موسم حرائق كندا في
المستقبل يحذر الخبراء من موجات جفاف وحر
شديد في الاشهر المقبله يرافقها زياده
معدلات التلوث الهواء الذي يتسبب بوفاه
سته ملايين الف شخص سنويا في العالم بحسب
منظمه الصحه العالميه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات